you could elaborate on that what the
government could do if the currency was
digital so firstly it will be
programmable which essentially means the
government has the ability to decide
what you can and what you can't spend
your money on now this is really
concerning because let's just say you
know you go to fill up your car with gas
they could turn around and actually not
allow you to spend your cbdc they won't
allow you to do that because perhaps you
spent you know you've bought too much
meat that week and you've reached your
pollution allowance because we're in
this climate crisis or we could even get
to a point where people are being
discriminated against for example
unvaccinated people at one point weren't
actually allowed to go into stores and
were only allowed to buy essential items
so they weren't allowed to go in on
chaperone so with a cbdc it's far more
efficient you could just program the
money to say well if you weren't a good
citizen and you haven't done what the
government told you to do you can't go
and spend the money how you wish so that
is that essentially is um some form of
discrimination and that becomes a lot
more efficient through a cbdc not to
mention the fact that if you go and like
something on twitter which the
government doesn't agree with perhaps
you're liking something to do with
freedom and the government might say
actually no you can't now go buy that
plane ticket to potentially go to
protest
because that's not what we want that
goes against what we're trying to do and
that's really concerning because if you
don't you might have freedom of speech
you might have your first amendment your
second amendment but if you don't have
the freedom of money then you do not
have freedom because you can stand on
your balcony you can stand on your
rooftop and you can say how these
authoritarian policies are unfair but if
nobody can hear you then essentially
you're going to have a real problem
you're not going to be able to start
fighting against the government if
nobody can hear you